wandavision was one of the most
complicated concepts we've seen in the
mcu so it's no surprise it was
challenging to film we're taking a look
at 20 of the hurdles they had to tackle
number one it's not funny elizabeth paul
bettany while in his three layer thick
vision makeup dripped purple snot on
elizabeth olsen while they were filming
a kissing scene and olson kinda made a
joke about it henceforth for some reason
paul thinks that elizabeth should be
called snotter elizabeth snotter olsen
as i think we can all agree to call her
number two while we're on the subject of
purple paint paul's makeup in those
black and white shots was difficult to
get right red doesn't look like red once
you take the color away but for some
reason blue does so they leaned away
from the red hues and into the blue and
that's why betany looked like a
blueberry for filming their inspiration
came from the actual black and white
sitcoms of the time where they used to
use blue lipstick on the actors because
red was so dark it didn't film like you
wanted it to they tested many different
shades and sheens of blue
number three playing with paint hues
wasn't the only practical effect to get
that accurate 50s feel they opted to use
practical levitating effects which
included lots of strings to puppeteer
flying objects around wanda the crew
were crouched under the island and in
the refrigerator if you could put a
camera behind there there would be a ton
of crew just trying to stay out of the
way olsen found the use of these
practical effects hilarious because
she's used to the big pyrotechnics and
huge stunts and now it was just
complicated to get a cloth to dance
around on the strings it was just so so
funny to watch
number four and now for humans on
strings
no stunt can be perfectly 100
safe except for maybe washing the dishes
and while wanda vision didn't have much
hand-to-hand combat they did have a ton
of long-flying shots on rigged but we
can't say the actors didn't enjoy
themselves olson isn't a fan of thrill
rides like roller coasters but she loves
a good flying stunt but all this hanging
about just looks super uncomfortable to
us
number five betany spent a lot of time
in the air fighting the guest appearance
he teased to the world he'd said he was
thrilled to be working with an actor
that he respected and that he was proud
of the hard work they'd done together
that actor was of course himself he
trolled the entire world but he still
did good work we won't discount it and
having an authentic fight with yourself
is hard just ask captain america
number six of course it takes a ton of
editing to put two betanise on the
screen at the same time but did you know
there was more cgi in one division than
in endgame given the show has eight hour
long episodes and end game is only three
hours perhaps that's reasonable but we
can cut that down to seven hours of cgi
because almost every effect used in the
first episode was done practically
number seven except for the choking
scene this was the first glimpse we had
into wandavision that not everything was
as it seems the scene was incredibly fun
for deborah joe rupp but also difficult
to do she kept asking wait what you want
me to do what no i don't get it wait
what it also broke out of the sitcom
style with the moment vision reaches
into the throat of mr heart and stops
him from choking they had a live
audience for this scene and one thing
you just can't do is break the fourth
wall because there's not a fourth wall
to break and yet for just a moment there
is when we get a glimpse of paul's face
number eight and the live audience was a
different experience for the cast it
feels very different you have to swing
for the fences as jess hall put it as if
things weren't complicated enough now
you're doing a 26 minute single take in
front of a live audience effectively
essentially filmed theater it was filmed
in front of a live audience which was
just bananas number nine while olson
wasn't going so far as to slip on banana
peels for the laugh she did manage to
take it too far once she turned a double
take into a triple take which is when
the director finally said that's it i've
had enough you've gone too far elizabeth
a triple take what a ridiculous concept
elizabeth was proud to have that moment
to have finally earned her that's too
much badge
number 10 and in the realm of things
being just too much kat dennings avoided
a close call when she'd spoken up about
just recovering from an injury to her
foot that left her in a boot uncertain
she could do a run across the field she
said here's the thing i'll do it i can't
guarantee my ankle will make it to
tomorrow so they brought in a stunt
person to do it for her
number 11. you know who didn't think
they'd ever be brought in again paul
bettany he went through a stressful
experience walking into the studio
thinking it was the end you know due to
his character being finished off in
endgame
only to find out about the new show
number 12. he wasn't the only one
feeling weird energy coming into the
show elizabeth was used to being able to
dissolve into an ensemble in the movies
to hear about wandavision she was
excited about the prospect of it but
intimidated to be taking up so much
screen time
number 13. no reason to fear when dick
van dyke is here he was brought in to
assist them through sitcom bootcamp
every decade of wandavision brought in
new challenges for the actors as quite
literally everything changed their
speech rhythm postures movement and
language all took a lot of work to
perfect for each era of tv olsen
clarified that it isn't specific to the
time it's specific to the sitcoms of the
time in the 70s there was a relaxation
of women and their behavior on tv which
changed everything for her character
number 14 except for that moment where
she had to go back in time as scarlet
witch when she first landed the job
olson was promised she would never need
to wear the original costume and that
promise was broken however given she
looked better than bethany there were no
complaints from her
number 15 it's not easy being betany he
had an incredibly long makeup process
which they managed to work down for the
tv show or they never would have gotten
anything accomplished 10 hours into
costume eight hours out not possible for
one division
number 16. another near impossibility
was crafting up witch runes trying to
get the look of the runes just right was
taxing on the artists because their
first attempt looked just too similar to
the wakandan alphabet and not witchy
enough
number 17. and what struggles might
catherine han have playing a witch the
shooting for agatha all along had to be
planned well in advance because it would
have been a nightmare to return to all
these locations for three second clips
so at the end of filming each decade
they would grab the shots they needed
number 18 jumping from decade to decade
may have been impressive but it wasn't
the most impressive thing betany and
olson's standout moments happened when
they were just together connecting and
sparkling the goodbye was a
heartbreaking scene and a tough one
emotionally so said director matt
shakman so they gave themselves a lot of
extra time to film it because it was
tricky to pull off
number 19 what was tricky for everyone
was coming up with the perfect words to
describe the importance of grief they
landed on what is grief if not love
persevering thanks to a final line tweak
from paul bettany the other struggle
with this scene was having vision come
off sympathetic and not preachy
number 20 it wasn't hard for paul to
sympathize with wanda's experience he
tragically lost his brother to a car
crash which helped him connect to the
show's message and bring a more
authentic understanding and performance
wandavision is worth a re-watch if
you're considering it now is a great
time with doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness in theaters did
wandavision bring out the nostalgia in
you what sitcoms were you watching on tv
that it reminded you of let us know in
the comments and thanks for hanging out
with us here at the things